çok heyecanlıyım
herkese Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
Ben Nur bilen Yavuzer bir Tekstil ve
Kozmetik markam var
markamın Creative
eşimle beraber kurduğumuz bir kliniğimiz
bir güzellik merkezimiz var aynı zamanda
uzman estetisyenin 5 yaşında bir oğlum
var anneyim 3G kedim ve 3 köpeğim var
sosyal medyada hayatıma işime dair
içerikler paylaşıyorum
influencer'ım
sevdiğim markalarla işbirliği yapıyorum
şu anda da çok yeni bir heyecanım var 4
mağazamızın içine bir kafe açmayı
planlıyorum
Ben inandığı sevdiğim
hayal ettiği şeylerinden şeylerin
peşinden koşan bir Düş yolcusuyum ve bu
gün Aslında size
Düşlerimin nasıl gerçek olduğunu
ve olmadığında da ne olduğunu anlatmaya
geldi
insanlar çoğunlukla hayatları boyunca
tek bir alanda uzmanlaşmaları
gerektiğini ve yaptıkları şeyden
sıkılsalar da yorulsalar da vazgeçmek
isteseler de bunu pek hakları
olmadıklarını düşünürler
ya da belki de Konfor alanlarından çok
fazla çıkmak istemezler bence yanılırlar
yanılıyorlar Çünkü hayat tek bir düş
için çok uzun
Aksi halde Her Akşam başka bir düş
görmez her sabah yeni bir güne
düş nedir Sabahtan beri düşle ilgili çok
şey dinlediniz belki üzerinden de
geçildi
düş gerçek olmamış olmalı Yani henüz
olmamış
ama bellekte tasarlanmış şeydir Peki
insan hiç bilmediği şeyi nasıl düşünür
ve nereden bilir Peki o zaman ve Bence
kesinlikle inandığım şey
düş aslında
Dış dünyada henüz olmamış ama iç
dünyamızda gerçekleştirdiğimiz
ve olma potansiyeli çok yüksek bir
gerçekliktir
şimdi Teşekkür ederim
şimdi biraz geriye döneceğim burada
olmama sebep olan başarılı sayılan
girişimlerim
geliştirdiğim yeteneklerim Mutlu bir
ailem ve uyum içinde olduğum bir
hayatımdan önce olmadan önce
neler vardı
Ben 1980'de burada Ankara'da dünyaya
geldim ve hayatta olmayı en sevdiğim yer
burası Ankara Çünkü birçok kişi gibi
gerçekten Özüm burada ve burada
olduğumda kendimi çok iyi hissediyorum
Buradan daha güzel bir yerde görmedim
çok mutlu bir çocuktum ta ki Erkek
kardeşim doğana kadar
bir erkeğin dünyaya gelişinin bizim
evimizde neden bu kadar dost aşılandı
karşılaştığını
karşılandığını ve babamı neden bu kadar
mutlu olduğunu hiç anlamlandıramamıştım
ve bundan da gerçekten çok mutsuz
olmuştum tam 5 yaşındaydım Bir erkeğin
bir kızdan daha değerli olduğunu
hissettiğimde
ve kendi kişisel yolculuğunda
çok sonradan fark ettim ki aslında Ben
hayatım boyunca güçlü olmaya çalışarak
başarılı olmaya çalışarak ayakları yere
basan biri olmaya çalışarak hep o 5
yaşındaki incinmiş kız çocuğunu
onurlandırmaya çalıştım
çok başarısız bir çocuktum Yani
bilmiyorum şu anda gerçekten çocukların
başarısız olma hakları neredeyse hiç yok
fakat Elimde değil yani Hem çok
başarısızdım hem çok yaramazdım Belki
erkek gibi davrandığım için çok
hareketliydim ve sınıf öğretmenlerim
İlkokuldan itibaren sınıfta olmamam için
sınıf dışındaki bütün sosyal
aktiviteleri gönderirlerdi beni işte
aklınıza ne gelirse Koru tiyatrodan halk
dansları bunların hepsini yaptım Annem
dünyanın en Anlayışlı ve kapsayıcı beni
olduğum gibi kabul eden insanı hala öyle
buradan bir teşekkür ediyorum ona beni
hiç zorlamadı tam tersine İyi olduğum
alanları her zaman genişletti
Ben hiçbir zaman Çarpım tablosunu
dağların isimlerini savaşlarını hiçbir
zaman ezberleyemedim ama dans ettim
enstrüman çaldım tiyatro yaptım yani
sosyal her şeyi yaptım aslında
lisede Güzel Sanatlar okudum başka bir
alternatifim yoktu çünkü
işte TED sınavları Anadolu Lisesi
sınavları gibi sınavlar var arı kolejimi
mezunuyum ortaokul sonuna kadar ve
dersler gittikçe zorlaşıyor Annem de
bunu fark ediyor Benim devam edebilmeme
imkan yok zaten çok zor geçiyorum güzel
sanatlar lisesi sınavlarına girdim Kemal
bölümünü kazandım
ve fark ettim ki gerçekten benim hayatta
olmak istediğim yer sahne yani şu an
olduğum yer ama böyle değil Tabi bu da
çok güzel ama ben çocukken hep şunu
hayal ettim burada
Nasıl anlatayım eyelinerı böyle ıslık
gibi uzun
notaları böyle en tiz notaları duvarlara
böyle çarptırıp getiren böyle kabarık
etekli bir sopran olacaktım ama olamadım
maalesef sınavı kazanamadım Tabi o yaşta
bir çocuk için sınav sınav kazanamamak
çok zor hele bir de bu yeteneğinizle
ilgili sınırdığınız bir şeyse Bir de o
yaşınıza kadar zaten o yetenekten başka
hiçbir şey de yapmayı öğrenmemişsiniz
gerçekten çok yıkıcı bir şey
sınavı kazanamadığımı öğrenip eve
geldiğim akşam evdeki piyano bir tabut
gibi evden çıktı ve O tabutun içinde
benim düşüm vardı
Ben 18 yaşındaydım bir düşün öyle
bildiğini öğrendiğinde
sonra gerçekten çok zordu
Ama şöyle bir şey var Hep aklımda Ve
kendimle ilgili fark ettiğim insan
hayatında başında olumsuz şeyler geldiği
zaman ya da planlamadığı beklemediği
şeyler olduğunda
burada başkalarını ve olayları suçlayıp
bu durumu böyle içinden çıkılmaz bir
hale getiriyor
Ben başıma kötü bir şey geldiğinde veya
planlamadığım gibi olduğunda ki bu
defalarca kez oldu
önüme çıkan Diğer yoldan gitmeyi ve
Orada zorlanmayı aslında hep tercih
ettim bu aslında bir Tekamül yani
geliştiğim yer burasıydı benim her zaman
dışarıda çok zor gibi görünen yeniden
başlamam gereken şeylerde Cesur
davrandım ve yapmaya çalıştım
yetenek sınavı ile devam edeceğimi
tahmin ettiğim için Tabii üniversite
puan çok düşüktü
Bu da sadece bilkent'te Turizm bölümüne
geçiyordu ve ertesi gün de ilahi bir
şekilde sadece onun kaydı vardı ve bütün
kayıtlar kapanmıştı önümde İki seçenek
vardı ya tekrar bir sene daha hazırlanıp
yetenek sınavına girecektim ya da Turizm
okuyacaktım çok kırılmıştım
devam etmek istemedim başka bir düş
lazımdı bana başka bir yol lazımdı ve
Aslında önümdeydi Turizm okudum çok da
zor okudum çok zorlandım Çünkü içinde
muhasebe olan satın alma olay yiyecek
içecek mutfak olan
mutfak olan diyorum Çünkü şu anda 42
yaşındayım O zaman çok zorlandım ama
İşime hiç yaramayan şey şu anda kafe
açarken Gerçekten inanılmaz bir şekilde
hafızamda ortaya çıkıyor Ve bana yardım
ediyor Yani aslında yaptığımız hiçbir
şey boşuna değil ve her şeyin bir sebebi
var
mezun olduktan sonra hemen çalışmaya
başladım
2001 yılı 21 yıl olmuş 21 yıldır
hayatımda çalışmadığım hiçbir zaman
olmadı Ben bu hayatta en çok çalışmayı
iyi biliyorum ve çok iyi yapıyorum yani
bana hangi işi verirseniz verin ben o
işi alırım ve yaparım
[Müzik]
teşekkür ederim
12 sene turizmde kariyer yaptım çok iyi
otellerde çok büyük acentalarda çalıştım
Avrupa'da bir derneğin bütün
kongrelerini Ben düzenledim 29 yaşında
organizasyon şirketimi kurdum
olabileceğim en iyi yerdeydim eşimle
tanıştım
ve İstanbul'a yerleştim ve beraber bir
klinik açmaya karar verdik Bu da benim
üçüncü düşünüm oldu aslında önüme gelen
yol diyebilirim ve ben bu yolu yine bir
düşe çevirdim
çok başarılı çok bilinen bir plastik
cerrahtı Ve baktım ki gerçekten klinikte
sadece onun karısı olarak varım yani
geliyorlar gidiyorlar reha'nın karısı
diyorlar Bu gerçekten Bence bir kadın
için bilmiyorum olabilecek en zor
sıfatlardan biri
maalesef Biz Kadınlar Ne yaparsak
yapalım Bu hayatta birinin kızı birinin
eşi birinin bir şeyi olmak sıfat olarak
önce geliyor ben burada isem Eğer
bu fikirle mücadelemi buna çok büyük bir
katkısı vardır Tabii ki eşim çok
başarılı beraber çok güzel şeyler yaptık
Ama benim de ben olmam gerekiyor yani
başka bir başka bir yolu yok bunun
kaleli'yi açtık 32 yaşında itibaren
birçok eğitim aldım
Türkiye'de birçok eğitim aldım Araba
Terapist oldum Medical makyajı makyajı
öğrendim ve uzun yıllar klinikte hem
işlem yaptım hem de orayı yönettim
sosyal medyadan hayatımızda çok yeni
girdiği zamanlarda çok şanslıydım Çünkü
güzellik ve moda gerçekten insanların
çok dikkatini çeken şu anda olduğu gibi
o zaman da çok etkileyici bir alandı bir
anda binlerce takipçim oldu Türkiye'nin
ilk güzellik koçu oldum Çünkü
danışmanlık veriyordum hangi
işlemlerinki ve uygun olduğunu
anlatıyordum klinlikte birçok şeyde
denediğim için aslında Hem hasta gibi
anlatabiliyordum hem de ezbere
anlatabiliyordum ikisini birleştirmiştim
sonra bir vlog açmaya karar verdim
sonra bir Kozmetik markası kurmak
istedik Çünkü her şeyi takip ediyoruz ve
Kozmetik markası için kalktı Kore'ye
gittik Çünkü biliyoruz gene üretim orada
arkasında hamilelik sürecim başladı çok
zor bir hamilelik süreciydi tüp bebek
tedavisi Gerçekten böyle kadınları
altüst eden hayatı var oluyor çünkü
benim başıma diye geliyor sorgulatan bir
dönem
o dönemde de bir Tekstil markası
Yarattım bu üzerimde gördüğünüz hani çok
en beyzik Aslında herkesin dolabında
olan şeyleri yapmak istedim herkes dedi
ki ya bunlar zaten var 40 kere yapıldı
sen tekrar niye yapacaksın
yapmak istedim çünkü
bir marka yaratacaksanız bir işe
girişecekseniz kimin ne yaptığı Sizi
ilgilendirmez Siz ortaya koyduğunuz şey
sizin varoluşunuzdur o başkalarına basit
gelebilir başkalarına gereksiz gelebilir
bu Sizi ilgilendirmez eleştirebilirler
beğenmeyebilirler Önemli olan gerçekten
yola çıkmak kadar önemli olan tek şey
insanın kendine inanmasıdır bu hayatta
ne yaptıysam
bilmiyorum oraya belki çok beğenince
gelecek ama ben sadece kendim için
yaptım ve yaptığım her şeyinde iyisini
yapmaya çalıştım Bence Evren bunu
duyuyor yani başkaları için yapılmış
başkalarına hizmet etmek için yapılmış
sadece para kazanmak için yapılmış
sadece ünlü olmak için yapılmış sadece
yapmış olmak şeyi yapılmış hiçbir şey
bir yere gitmiyor eğer onun için de siz
varsanız size ait bir şey varsa Evren
buna kesinlikle cevap veriyor Çünkü
aslında Siz kendi aidiyetinizi
gerçekleştirmiş oluyorsunuz
dediğim gibi 4 mağazamızı açıyoruz çok
güzel bir Ekim var ekibim var hayatım
boyunca kalabalık çalışmayı ekiple
çalışmayı her zaman çok önemsedim
beraber çalıştığım arkadaşlarım çok
kıymetli insanlar
Evet ben belki görmüyorum ama arkada çok
büyük bir ekip var
Hepsine buradan teşekkür ediyorum
burada olmak çok güzel
böyle bir hikaye yazmış olmak benim için
çok güzel
şanslı mıyım bazen bunu çok duyuyorum
Bunu sen çok şanslısın düşünüyorum şans
nedir acaba diye şans insanın önüne
gelen yollardır ama o şansı kullanabilen
insanlar cesaretli insanlardır düş
kurabilen insanlardır dediğim gibi düş
henüz olmamış bir gerçektir ve eğer ona
hizmet ederseniz Eninde sonunda
potansiyeli varsa eğer gerçeğe
dönecektir Bu yüzden düş kurmaktan
vazgeçmeyin
kuşkunun kurduğunuz düş için çok çalışın
O kadar çok çalışın ki zorlanın
zorlandığınız yerde gelişin
bunu yaparken kendinizi ve başkalarını
önemseyin ve onlara karşı iyi olun
Gerçekten iyi olmak çok kıymetli bir şey
hayat kötü olmaktan daha hızlı bir
şekilde iyi olmaya cevap veriyor buna
%100 eminim
ve şunu söyleyeceğim getirirken
düş kurmak çok güzel bir şey düşün
peşinden gitmek de çok güzel bir şey Ama
eğer elinizden geleni yaptıysanız ve
olmuyorsa o Düşten vazgeçin
yeni düş kurmaktan da hiçbir zaman
vazgeçmeyin Çünkü hayat tek bir düş için
çok
Teşekkür ederim Teşekkürler
[Müzik]